je propose qu'on débute de notre réunion
de ce jour avec l'audition de Madame
Laurence Bou secrétaire d'État en charge
des affaires européennes madame ministre
cher Laurence bienvenue nous sommes
heureux de pouvoir vous accueillir
aujourd'hui pour vous puissiez nous
rendre compte du dernier Conseil
européen des 14 et et 15 décembre
dernier je voudrais auparavant saluer
parmi nous une délégation de
fonctionnaires parlementaires Ukrainiens
qui se trouvve dans les cabines pour des
soucis
d'interprétation et qui sont présents
ici aujourd'hui à Paris dans le cadre
d'un accord de coopération conclue entre
l'Assemblée nationale et l'assemblée
ukrainienne la Rada voilà bienvenue à
vous et donc il vont suivre nos échange
aujourd'hui le dernier sommet d'ailleurs
de de la semaine passée directement lié
à la situation ukrainienne et en
approuvant les l'ouverture des
négociations d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine
et la Moldavie la les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement ont pris une décision
extrêmement importante peut-être
vraisemblablement l'une des plus
importantes de ces dernières décennies
et vous serez évidemment amené à nous le
à nous le dire aujourd'hui c'est un
message clair qui est envoyé à plus d'un
titre d'abord à l'attention de de nos
amis Ukrainiens qui se battent avec
beaucoup de courage de détermination de
volonté pour recouvrir leur liberté leur
indépendance et leur souveraineté et
puis à l'encontre aussi et à l'égard de
la Russie qui mène une guerre injuste et
brutale et par cette volonté ouverture
vers l'Ukraine et la Moldavie nous
disons très clairement à Vladimir
Poutine que nous n'abandonnons pas ces
pays et que nous serons durablement à
leur côté et que au fond nous lions nos
destins les uns aux autres pour les
décennies à venir et je crois que ce
message politique est extrêmement
important nous ne céderons rien ni de
nos valeurs ni de notre territoire
européen et ce ce message très clair
était attendu dans un moment où
comptetenu de ce qui peut se passer
ailleurs dans le monde notamment moi je
pense au conflit au Proche Orient et
bien l'actualité du conflit ukrainien
qui perdure et qui a
peut-être qui n'a jamais été aussi
intense notamment sur la ligne de front
était passé un peu au second plan et je
pense que la décision qui a été prise la
semaine passée permet de bien de prendre
conscience que ce que cette guerre se
poursuit que nous devons être
durablement au côté des des Ukrainiens
jusqu'à la victoire et jusqu'à la paix
dans les conditions qu'auront choisi les
ukrainiens et leurs dirigeants dans ce
contexte il faut évidemment regretter
qu'en raison de l'opposition de la
Hongrie dirigée par Victor Orban le
Conseil européen n'est pas été en mesure
d'approuver l'ctro à ce pays d'une aide
de 50 milliards d'euros sur la période
2014 2024 pardon 2027 euh et si le
blocage persistait certaines sources
évoquent la possibilité que cette aide
soit octroyé dans un cadre A26 avec une
reprise de la garantie revenant à la
Hongrie ou par la mise en place de près
bilatéraux nous serions évidemment
intéressés de pouvoir vous entendre sur
ce sujet
un sujet annexe qui est qui n'est pas
lié au au dernier conseil européen
immédiatement mais qui l'actualité de de
ce jour puisqueun accord a été trouvé
sur le pacte asile et immigration je
pense que ce serait important que vous
puissiez aussi nous en dire
éventuellement un mot dans les questions
ou les réponses ou lors que vous le
souhaitez c'est une décision importante
puisque ce Pact est maintenant négocié
depuis de nombreuses années à Bruxelles
entre les différents pays européens
entre le Parlement européen et et les
différentes institutions européennes et
et l'accord permet d'apporter une
réponse efficace dans la gestion des des
phénomènes migratoires la maîtrise des
flux la protection des frontières
extérieures le renforcement de la
solidarité entre les États-membres et
évidemment un meilleur accueil des
demandeurs d'asile et des mesures plus
efficace dans l'éloignement de celles et
ceux qui n'ont pas leur place sur le
continent européen et moi j'ai la
conviction fermement ancré que le niveau
européen est le meilleur niveau pour
régler efficacement les sujets
migratoire avec humanité et fermeté et
donc moi je me réjouis de la décision
qui a été prise et adoptée hier cette
nuit plutôt entre les ce matin tôt ce
matin entre les entre les différentes
institutions donc merci voilà ce que
pouz vous dire en préambule merci pour
votre présence et je vous cède
immédiatement la
parole merci monsieur le Président merci
cher Pierre Alexandre Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés et je salue à mon
tour les fonctionnaires Ukrainiens qui
sont avec nous
aujourd'hui alors c'est
évidemment un plaisir et un honneur de
vous présenter les principaux sujets qui
ont été traités lors du Conseil européen
des 14 et 15 décembre et vous saviez que
nous avions placé beaucoup d'attente
dans ce Conseil européen et je crois
qu'on peut dire que l'Union européenne a
été au rendez-vous les sujets
prioritaires qui ont été traités sont
comme vient de le dire le président le
soutien à l'Ukraine et bien sûr la
question de
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne la
révision à mi-parcours du cadre
financier
pluriannuel le conflit qui est toujours
en cours au Proche Orient les questions
de sécurité et de défense européenne et
puis les chefs d'État et de gouvernement
on une discussion stratégique sur les
migrations et puis ils ont eu des
échanges sur le suivi de la COP 28 et
enfin de la lutte contre le discours les
discours de haine
voilà donc quelques quelques détails sur
chacun de de ces points en commençant
par les
décisions que comme vous le disiez
monsieur le Président d'importance sur
en matière
d'élargissement et je crois qu'on peut
dire que les États-membres ont été
fondamentalement
alignés puisque nous avons décidé
puisqu'ils ont décidé d'ouvrir des
négociations d'adhésion à l'Ukraine et à
la Moldavie et vous savez que la Hongrie
a fait fait le choix de pas de ne pas
participer à la décision sur l'Ukraine
et donc de préserver l'unité des
Européens la décision d'ouvrir les
négociations d'adhésion était aussi et
je crois que c'est également important
un message politique très fort envoyé à
Moscou à la fois parce
que ça représente la vision
géostratégique de l'élargissement de
l'Union européenne et puis dans la
lignée de ce que le président de la
République avait rappelé à Bratislava
fin mai dans son discours à globseek
c'est évidemment aussi un message
d'espoir à un moment très décisif et
très attendu par les autorités et le
peuple ukrainien alors qu'il continue de
lutter au quotidien contre la guerre
d'agression russe et c'est aussi la
réaffirmation du soutien sans faille que
l'Union européenne apporte à l'Ukraine
depuis le début de la guerre dans tous
les domaines et dans la
durée et je crois qu'il est euh
essentiel de souligner les messages qui
ont été adressés par le Conseil européen
à l'Ukraine à la fois sur la question
des besoins militaires sur les
engagements européens de sécurité ou
encore sur les travaux en cours sur les
avoirs gelés et des engagements qui
s'inscrivent bien sûr en complément de
ceux qui sont déjà discuté avec
l'Ukraine au plan bilatéral par les
États-membres alors il n'y a pas eu que
l'Ukraine même si cétait essentiel
puisque le Conseil européen a aussi
décidé d'octroyer le statut de pays
candidat à la Géorgie sous réserve
qu'elle met en œuvre les réformes
nécessaires en matière d'état de droit
et nous avons aussi envoyé un signal
très clair à la Bosnie-Herzégovine pour
lesquels les négociations d'adhésion
seront ouvertes lorsque les réformes
nécessaires auront été mises en
œuvre et puis dans le même temps et vous
savez à quel point c'était important
pour nous on en a déjà discuté ici il a
toujours été très clair pour nous qu'une
réforme de l'Union européenne devrait
accompagner
l'élargissement et cette réforme elle
demande d'abord que nous elle vise
d'abord à adapter nos politiques
communes à en revoir les priorités le
financement mais aussi à assurer le
fonctionnement efficace des institutions
européennes et donc le Conseil européen
a demandé à la Présidence belge du
conseil de travailler à la adoption
d'une feuille de route sur la réforme de
l'Union européenne d'ici à l'été
2024 et cet équilibre qu'on a trouvé à
Grenade entre l'élargissement et la
réforme de l'Union se réflétera aussi
dans la préparation du prochaine agenda
stratégique pour
2024-2029 le Conseil européen s'est donc
mis d'accord pour adopter cet agenda
stratégique d'ici à l'été
prochain
et il s'inscrit dans la lignée de toutes
les décisions qui ont été prises depuis
2019 le plan de relance européen la
mutualisation des achats de vaccins le
financement par l'Union européenne
d'armes pour soutenir l'Ukraine et
également la nécessité de devenir pour
l'Europe de devenir plus souveraine
voilà et donc l'idée c'est de travailler
à poursuivre et amplifier ses priorités
pour les C prochaines
années et je crois que c'est objectifs
politiques sont certes ambitieux mais
ils sont partagés et ils seront le
ciment de l'unité des Européens à un
moment il nous faut absolument nous
renforcer à cet égard d'ailleurs
permettez-moi de saluer monsieur le
Président et Madame la député larnos
votre proposition de résolution sur les
suites de la conférence pour l'avenir de
l'Europe qui a été définitivement adopté
par la représentation nationale le mois
dernier vous avez effectué un un travail
très riche avec beaucoup de propositions
notamment sur l'élargissement et les
grandes réformes institutionnelles et
bien évidemment ces travaux servent à
enrichir la réflexion au niveau européen
et je crois que nous convergeons sur les
objectifs notamment bâtir une Europe
plus souveraine mais aussi plus agile et
plus proche de ses
concitoyens alors ensuite euh je vais
passer à la révision du cadre financier
pluriannuel donc là le travail technique
s'est beaucoup accéléré les dernières
semaines et le président du Conseil
européen a présenté jusqu'à cette
jusqu'à la veille du conseil européens
de nouvelles propositions budgétaires
vous savez que ce cadre a été gelé lors
du Conseil européen pourquoi est-ce que
les négociations sont difficiles et mais
parce que nous cherchons à trouver le
bon équilibre entre limiter la facture
pour les États-membres tout en assurant
la pérennité du financement des
priorités essentielles et on pense bien
évidemment euh au soutien à l'Ukraine à
travers la facilité mais aussi à la
souveraineté technologique ou encore à
la gestion efficace et équilibré
d'migration et je crois qu'il est juste
de dire que sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
les positions de tous les États-membres
se sont
rapprochées les États-membres sont
désormais d'accord sur la nécessité de
cette révision sur ses composantes et
nous sommes très proches d'un accord ce
qui explique la convocation d'un Conseil
européen extra ordinaire début 2024 le
1er février pour finaliser la révision
du cadre financier pluriannuel et je
suis persuadé que nous pouvons faire
mieux que en juillet 2020 où ce conseil
avait duré 4 jours avant de conclure sur
le CFP mais nous le referons s'il en est
besoin alors avec euh évidemment
l'élargissement et et le cadre
budgétaire vient la nécessité de
renforcer notre souveraineté en matière
de
défense vous savez
que la donner à l'Union une ambition
géopolitique passe évidemment par une
ambition économique et donc par un
effort industriel pour renforcer nos
capacités de production et de renforcer
notre maîtrise des technologies de
défense c'est bien évidemment nécessaire
pour assurer la résilience des chaînes
d'approvisionnement de nos armées il
s'agit aussi de poursuivre la
construction en Europe de la profondeur
stratégique dont l'Ukraine a besoin pour
tenir dans la durée et à cette fin le
Conseil européen a permis d'appeler
l'Union européenne à se doter d'une
stratégie sur l'industrie de défense qui
s'inscrira dans laquelle s'inscrira un
instrument de long terme visant à
favoriser les investissements et les
acquisitions conjointes que l'on appelle
IP et en février la Commission
présentera une stratégie de
défense le Conseil européen a aussi
réaffirmé sa volonté d'abourtir
rapidement sur la réforme de l'asile et
desimmigration et vous l' avz vu un
accord Pierre Alexandre enlade de
souligner a été trouvé ce matin entre le
Conseil et le Parlement européen sur
l'ensemble des textes du pacte asile et
immigration je veux saluer ici à Fabiane
Keller pour ses efforts c'est une grande
avancée pour la France et vous savez que
le Président de la République s'est
beaucoup battu pour cela non seulement
pendant la présidence française de
l'Union européenne mais également ces
derniers
mois je crois qu'on peut dire que cet
accord démontre la capacité des
Européens à trouver des solutions qui
préservent nos valeurs communes et les
intérêts de
chacun et il va également permettre de
préserver ce qui est une des plus
grandes réussites de l'Union européenne
qui est la liberté de circulation de
tous les citoyens européens au sein de
l'Union
européenne donc comme le disait le
Président il nous permet de nous doter
d'une nouvelle politique d'asile et
migration qui est à la fois plus juste
et plus humaine et qui renforce nos nos
frontières extérieures pour mieux
maîtriser les flux d'immigration et
permettre de protéger nos
citoyens il y a également un volant
important de solidarité vous l'avez
souligné entre les États-membres afin de
partager équitablement l'effort et je
crois aussi un vrai élément de dignité
dans l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile et
notamment des
mineurs les demandes des demandeurs
d'asile seront traité avec plus
d'efficacité le retour des personnes non
éligible à l'asile sera
ficilité et donc responsabilité humanité
et solidarité je crois sont les trois
mots qui qui caractérise cet accord en
parallèle nous allons évidemment
continuer de travailler au renforcement
de nos liens avec les
pays-tiers les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement l'ont rappelé cette
coopération se veut mutuellement
bénéfique tenant compte des intérêts de
chaque parti et dans le plein respect de
nos obligations internationales comme
européennes il y a évidemment une
discussion sur le proche orient vous
savez que les États-membres ont des
positions qui peuvent être différentes
sur le sujet mais en revanche sur les
objectifs tout le monde est unanime et
les objectifs sont clairs c'est la
sécurité d'Israël la paix et la sécurité
de la région la résolution de la crise
humanitaire à Gaza et la défense du
droit international
humanitaire la France a aussi rappelé la
priorité accordée à la libération
inconditionnelle des éages détenus par
le Hass et nous mettrons tout en œuvre
pour les faire libérer et je voudrais
ici répéter nos condoléances à la
famille d'Élia Toledano l'un de nos
otages qui a été retrouvé décédé
vendredi dernier et je crois qu'on peut
dire qu'au plan humanitaire il y a une
plus grande convergence des
États-membres et notamment en faveur
d'une trêve qui doit conduire à un
cesser le feu puisque les chefs d'État
et de gouvernement ont convenu de
poursuivre et renforcer la coordination
des différentes initiatives
humanitaires sur le volet sécuritaire le
président de la République a proposé une
coordination renforcée des dispositifs
pour la sécurité maritime dans le
détroit d'ormous et en mer Rouge vous
savez que l'Union européenne il y a déjà
euh une présence et certains de ses
États-membres avec les dispositifs
Atalante et AG Nord et nous croyons que
l'Union européenne peut jouer un rôle
important dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et les actions
déstabilisatrices de cette qui ont lieu
dans cette
région et puis bien sûr euh il y a un
angle politique avec la volonté partagée
par tous d'avancer sur un sur la
solution des deux États qui a été
également réaffirmé euh et là je
voudrais souligner que la ministre
Catherine Colona s'est rendue en Israël
et dans les Territoires palestiniens le
dimanche 17 décembre où elle a pu
rappeler ses grands principes et à
Beyrouth le 18 décembre où elle a
évidemment insisté sur la nécessité
d'éviter un embrasement régional et
appelé à mettre fin à la vacance
présidentielle le président de la
République quant à lui se rendra
prochainement dans la région pour être
au côté de nos forces qui sont déployées
depuis plusieurs
années une pensée aussi ici pour notre
collègue du Consulat général de France
qui est mort suite des à la suite de ses
blessures lors d'un bombardement
israélien à Rafa la France a bien
évidemment condamné ce bombardement et
exigé la lumière par les autorité
israélienne sur les circonstances de ce
bombardement enfin et ce sera le dernier
point
la COP 28 où je crois qu'on peut se
féliciter d'obtention d'un compromis
made in Europe en bon français comme
l'ont salué les représentants de l'Union
européenne donc avec l'objectif d'une
transition juste équitable ordonnée à 1
degr et demi cette COP a permis
d'adopter des objectifs pour tripler la
production des énergies renouvelables
d'ici 2030 et enclencher un mouvement
global de transition hors des énergies
fossiles c'est historique et là l'Union
européenne s'est je crois distinguée par
sa
volonté de porter un programme très
ambitieux notamment son engagement
auprès des pays les plus vulnérables au
changement climatique pour trouver des
solutions d'atténuation d'adaptation et
bien sûr de
financement et voici en quelques mots
les principaux résultats à retenir du
Conseil européen je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre d'avoir
rendu compte dans le détail avec
précision des conclusions du du dernier
Conseil européen et j'en viens
maintenant aux orateurs de groupe en
commençant par le groupe Renaissance
madame constance legrip pour 3
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre à mon tour de
souligner au nom des députés du groupe
Renaissance l'importance des décisions
prises par le dernier Conseil européen
en matière
d'élargissement le signal politique
géopolitique géostratégique envoyé par
les décisions prises en matière
d'élargissement commencer les
négociations d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine
et avec la Moldavie accorder le statut
de pays candidat à la Géorgie sous
réserve de la mise en œuvre des
recommandations faites il y a quelques
semaines par la Commission européenne
sont des décisions extrêmement
importantes et on voit vraiment le
signal que l'élargissement est la seule
perspective géopolitique
géostratégique crédible sérieuse valable
à l'échelle de notre continent pour
assurer la stabilité et la sécurité et
la paix et et à l'heure où la garde
ression menée par le le régime du
kréelin contre l'Ukraine se poursuit
alors que s'ouvre un hiver très
difficile pour nos amis ukrainien il
faut le le souligner alors bien sûr la
concrétisation et de l'aide financière
et et de l'aide militaire et sa
poursuite par je dirais les les
puissances occidentales à commencé par
les pays de l'Union européenne reste le
le défi mais n nous sommes tout à fait
déterminés à poursuivre dans cette dans
cette direction nous sommes parfaitement
conscients également je tiens à le dire
et je tiens à le dire à à toutes celles
ceux qui qui s'intéressent à à nos débat
cet après-midi que le processus de
négociation et le processus d'adhésion
vont être des processus extrêmement
longs extrêmement longs laborieux qu'il
y a des efforts considérabl qui auront à
être menés par les pays candidats bien
évidemment notamment sur le chemin de la
consolidation de l'État de droit on va
dire cela ainsi mais que nous aurons
nous aussi des réformes à mener
parallèlement bien sûr sur notre
gouvernance nos processus décisionnels
nos priorités politiques nos choix
budgétaires la redéfinition peut-être de
certaines politiques essentielles comme
la politique régionale ou la politique
agricole commune et que ce travail-là
nous avons à le mener également je
dirais en responsabilité avant que de
parachever le processus d'élargissement
nous en sommes parfaitement euh
conscient euh vous avez déjà parlé parce
que je voulais également le le souligner
et et et m'en réjouir de de l'accord
conclu ce matin tôt sur le pacte asile
et immigration c'est très important et
puis ça m bien je dirais en regard ce
que nous faisons sur le plan législatif
franco-français et ce qui est fait de
manière concertée au plan européen et et
tout cela est est parfaitement je dirais
cohérent et et et et
concerté je voudrais juste terminer par
une petite question sur un sujet alors
ça sort un tout petit peu pardonnez-moi
madame la ministre mais je profite de
votre présence du champ de de
de la du dernier Conseil européen mais
que pouvez-vous nous dire exactement de
la position française sur le règlement
sur l'intelligence artificielle parce
qu'il y a eu un accord politique les
trilogues ont été concluants mais il
semblerait quand même qu'il y ait encore
des ajustements à attendre merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup la parole est à
thba François pour le groupe
rassemblement national et pour 3 minutes
je vous remcie monsieur le président
madame la secrétaire d'État chers
collègues lors du Conseil européen qui a
eu lieu le 14 et 15 décembre dernier les
dirigeants des États-membres ont pu
aborder le sujet de l'élargissement de
l'Union européenne qui concerne
désormais de plus en plus d'états et
maintenant l'Ukraine et la Moldavie mais
également d'autres pays des Balcans
occidentaux tels que la Bosnie et en
plus la Géorgie selon une étude
européenne dévoilée en octobre 2023
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine lui ferait
bénéficier d'un montant de plus de 186
milliards d'euros sur 7 ans c'est un
montant qui est considérable et qui
augmenterait de fait la contribution des
autres États déjà membres de l'Union
européenne dont la France qui je le
rappelle est contributrice net au budget
de l'Union européenne et une finé les
contribuables français alors que
plusieurs classements internationaux
classent l'Ukraine comme étant l'un des
pays les plus corrompus au monde une
adhésion de l'Ukraine dans l'Union
européenne ouvrirait la porte à de
toutes à quelques formes potentielle de
malversation à l'image de nombreux
scandales de corruption qui touchent
l'Ukraine depuis le début de l'invasion
russe l'élargissement de l'Union à
certains pays des Balcans occidentaux
comme la Bosnie ouvrirait également la
porte à différents trafics qui touchent
malheureusement très lourdement et
gravement ces pays en effet selon les
chiffres du ministère de l'Intérieur
français les Balcans continuent d'être
la principale filière de trafic d'armes
vers la France ce qui posera évidemment
un réel problème pour la sécurité de
compatriotes en cas d'adhésion de ces
pays à l'Union européenne ma question
est la suivante madame la secrétaire
d'État comment justifiez-vous auprès des
autres pays des Balcans l'accélération
de l'avancement de l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne alors que
d'autres pays tels que la Macédoine sont
candidats depuis près de 24 ans pour
devenir membbrre de l'Union européenne
et pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît nous
détailler le cadendrier attendu pour une
une adhésion effective de l'Ukraine et
de la Moldavie à l'Union européenne je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Daniel bonau pour le groupe de la
France insoumise et pour 3 minut
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je voudrais vous interroger sur
les éléments que vous avait
abordé tout à l'heure concernant la
situation et le la positionnement de du
conseil sur la situation en Israël et en
Palestine en particulier sur la
situation en 6 Jordanie dimanche dernier
le ministère palestinien de de la santé
indiquit que 505 palestiniens dont 101
enfants auraient été tués de depuis le
début de l'année 2023 et en particulier
les attaques de Colon israélien se sont
multiplié depuis l'attaque du Hamas du
du 7 octobre l'Union européenne a
indiqué envisager imposer un certain
nombre de sanctions contre les colons
coupables de violence en six-jordanie en
se basant sur le régime mondial de
sanction de l'Union en matière de droits
humains ces mesures pourraient prendre
la forme d'une interdiction de visa et
d'un contrôle le plus strict des
produits issus des colonies euh la
présidente de la Commission elle-même
avait déclaré être en faveur de ces de
ces sanctions je rappelle également que
euh le l'engagement de de l'Europe et
deunion européenne euh sur ce sujet date
de plusieurs décennies en 1973 par
exemple euh à l'occasion du sommet de
Copenhague elle avait approuvé euh la
résolution sur la nécessité du retrait
d'Israël des des territoires occupés le
respect de la souveraineté des États
dans des frontières sûres en 1980 elle
s'était accordée à nouveau sur le
principe du droit des Palestiniens à
l'autodétermination elle a joué aussi un
rôle au moment de la fin de de l'tifada
et notamment avec la question des
accords commerciaux et qui nous semble
être un levier important je voulais donc
vous interroger pour savoir euh comment
euh ce ces ces éléments ont évoluer ou
pas sur le type de de mesure que
prendrait l'Union européenne ensemble ou
un certain nombre d'États peut-être de
manière coordonnée si si l'ensemble des
États de l'Union ne serait pas investi
dans cette dans ces démarches pour
permettre que cessent les attaques
contre les civils palestiniens en
sjordanie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Sabine pour le groupe démocrate et pour
3 minutes merci monsieur président merci
madame la ministre pour vos propos
liminires euh vous avez bien souligné
que le Conseil
a réaffirmé le
soutien financier et militaire à
l'Ukraine mais néanmoins on voit quand
même que des doutes commencent à émerger
il y a pas que la Hongrie il y a aussi
la Slovaquie et peut-être aussi dans
d'autres pays où euh les extrêmes
commencent à émerger qu'on met un peu en
cause ce soutien et peut-être plus euh
plus préoccupant aussi euh j'ai vu que
la présidente de la commission de
défense du Bundestag a très récemment
fait une déclaration en considérant que
l'aide financière de la France vers
l'Ukraine serait dérisoire par rapport
aux dépenses euh consenti par
l'Allemagne donc il y a quand même un
peu des des dissensions sûrement aussi
aussi au niveau du Conseil comment vous
appréciez cette situation et de là juste
peut-être un mot aussi sur la défense
européenne le Conseil a aussi appelé le
Haut représentant la Commission et
l'Agence européenne de défense à mettre
en place une BTD européen qu'on peut
appeler de ses vœux surtout quand on
voit qu'on a 20 modèles de chars
différents 17 modèles d'avion et cetera
où les Américains ont très peu ça
pourrait engendrer une économie entre
24,5 milliards d'euros et 75 milliards
d'euros si on se mettait ensemble il
reste néanmoins nos industries sont
aussi en concurrence et les outils qu'on
met en place restent relativement
faibles par rapport aux besoins merci
merci beaucoup la parole est à Félicie
gerérrard pour le groupe horizon et pour
3 minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre les 14 et 15 décembre
le Conseil européen a adopté de
nouvelles conclusions suite au contexteé
politique tendu de ces dernières années
mois et semaines l'ouverture de
négociations pour l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine et de la Moldavie à l'Union
européenne envoie un signal fort à la
Russie réaffirmer l'appartenance de
l'Ukraine à la famille de l'Union
européenne était un des objectifs de ce
conseil à ce titre je voudrais revenir
en particulier sur les aides militaires
et financières que l'Union octroie à
l'Ukraine si le sujet était peu traité
dans les médias nous savons que la
dernière offensive ukrainienne fut un
échec et que le nombre de soldats tués
continue d'augmenter or nous savons
aussi qu'historiquement les Russes ont
toujours profité des périodes hivernales
pour renforcer leurs attaques et assoir
davantage leur position madame la
ministre mes questions sont donc les
suivantes le volume d'aide prévu par
l'Union pour l'Ukraine est-il adapté à
la potentielle intensification du
conflit durant la période hivernale et
enfin le Conseil a confirmé la nécessité
pour l'union de renforcer sa propre
défense de ce fait les investissement
consacrés au renforcement de l'autonomie
d'action de l'Union en matière de
défense sont-ils équili bré par rapport
au soutien qu'il est nécessaire de
continuer d'apporter à l'Ukraine je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est au
président chassigne pour le groupe GDR
et pour 3 minutes merci monsieur le
Président bon nous avons noté
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
avec l'Ukraine nous en avons pris acte
et avec le constat que le Conseil se
déclare suffisamment satisfait des
progrès qui ont été réalisés depuis le
printemps 202 de euh quand le l'Ukraine
et la Moldavie d'ailleurs ont été
déclarés comme pays candidat donc en 18
mois et en plein conflit semble-t-il il
y a eu des progrès extrêmement
importants qui font qu'en 18 mois on
passe de candidat euh en adhérant
potentiel alors là ma question quels
sont ces progrès qui ont peut être fait
notamment en temps de guerre est-ce que
par exemple ça concerne euh les normes
agricoles euh qu'on appelle les clauses
miroir qu'on a du mal à faire à faire
respecter par des pays tiers euh est-ce
que l'Ukraine a évolué par rapport à ces
normes phytosanitaires euh au regard en
particulier d'une agriculture qui
extrêmement intensive qui est
extrêmement euh est extrêmement
productiviste donc on peut se poser
cette questionl où est-ce que par
exemple concernant les différences de
niveau de salaire il y a des
négociations qui ont pu commencer parce
que on se doute bien qu'il y a un risque
terrible de délocalisation industrielle
d'ailleurs c'est pas pour rien que les
camionneurs polonais manifestent et
bloquent des points de passage à la
frontière pour lutter contre la
facilitation de d'ukrainien travaillant
dans l'Union européenne voilà c'est les
questions que je pose là-dessus parce
que j'étaé un peu surpris par par le par
le délai de 18 mois et cette rapidité
donc à considérer qu'il y avait eu des
progrès ça veut donc dire que le
processus sera suffisamment long après
pour concrétiser sans doute les progrès
qui peuvent qui pourront encore être
fait la deuxième chose je voulais
revenir sur le le Moyen-Orient je vux
revenir sur le Moyen-Orient il y a il y
a deux notamment deux affirmations qui
ont été faites c'est celle d'unité de
principe autour autour du droit d'Israël
à se défendre tout en étant attaché au
respect du droit international est-ce
qu'on peut considérer que donc les voies
françaises notamment à l'Assemblée
nationale qui avaient considéré que le
soutien à Israël devait être en soutien
sans conditions est-ce que est-ce que on
considère toujours que la France ne met
pas de conditions au soutien c'estd
notamment le fait ce qui se passe sur la
bande de Gaza en terme de massacre d'une
population qu'en est-il par rapport à
l'pposition française là-dessus qu'on
peut trouver assez timide d'ailleurs
dans les réponses que l'on peut avoir
notamment pendant les
questions au Gouvernement et enfin
deuxième chose la solution à deux états
et semble-t-il reconnu que par tout le
monde puisque on tout chacun considère
au niveau deunion européenne que la
résolution du confliit palestinien doit
se faire avec deux États mais dans ce
cas-là pourquoi la France pourquoi la
France ne reconnaît pas l'État de
Palestine pourquoi il y a pas une
volonté de reconnaître l'État de
Palestine pour qu'on puisse aller vers
une solution à de état je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre vous
avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président merci
pour vos
questions madame legrip alors sur le
règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est de trouver le bon équilibre entre
régulation et innovation donc l'idée
c'est de réguler les usages mais pas
forcément de réguler les technologies en
gros notre objectif c'est de d'avoir le
cadre réglementaire qui va nous
permettre de ne pas reproduire ce qui a
été fait avec les gfam où on a quatre
entreprises américaines qui dominent
totalement le marché là on veut laisser
des entreprises européennes se
développer se développer en Europe
conforme à nos valeurs à notre mode de
vie et à notre état d'esprit et c'est
pour ça qu'on pousse un petit peu la
commission pour aller plus loin que ce
qu'on a pour le moment euh monsieur le
député François les travaux et les
chiffres que vous avez cités je crois
qu'on peut dire qu'ils sont hors sol et
n'ont été validé par aucun pays ni par
la commission ni par aucune institution
européenne et en plus ils sont d'autant
plus hors sol que comme vous le savez
nous allons devoir réformer nos
politiques européennes et donc les
budgets qui vont avec et donc la
gouvernance qui va derrière ce qui va
prendre et vous le disiez vous-même pas
mal de temps
les pays ne rentreront dans l'Union
européenne que lorsque ou à condition
qu'ils satisfassent absolument aux
règles d'État de droit et donc ce que
nous leur demandons et je reviendrai
là-dessus pour Monsieur Chassin c'est de
mettre leurs
institutions aux normes et aux standards
européens en matière d'état de droit ce
qui va aussi effectivement prendre du
temps pour que ce soit complet en ce qui
concerne la Macédoine du Nord la
différence est que pendant très
longtemps la Macédoine n'a pas fait
beaucoup de progrès sous l'impulsion de
la France pendant la présidence
française de l'Union européenne il y a
eu un accord entre la Macédoine du Nord
et la Bulgarie pour avancer dans le
processus accord qui est conditionné à
l'adoption de certaines modifications de
la constitution de Macédoine du Nord qu'
sur laquelle la Macédoine du Nord s'est
mis d'accord avec la Bulgarie et ils
n'ont toujours pas rastifié ces
changements de constitution donc
effectivement pour l'instant ils ne
peuvent pas avancer mais nous avons bon
espoir que ils arrivent à le faire assez
rapidement madame la députée auono en ce
qui concerne les la colonisation
israélienne en sisjordanie et à
Jérusalem nous le disons très clairement
cette politique est illégale en droit
international elle sape tous les efforts
qui visent à une paix juste et durable
et elle menace la solution des deux
états et c'est pourquoi la France
condamne très régulièrement les annonces
israéliennes qui sont liées à la
colonisation euh ce que nous faisons
d'abord c'est des mesures concrètes qui
ont été prises au niveau européen pour
différencier le territoire de l'État
d'Israël qui est reconnu en droit
international ce sont les frontières de
67 et les territoires palestiniens
occupés en ce qui concerne les produits
qui viennent de ces régions comme vous
savez il y a un droit européen qui
demande la transparence sur ces produits
qu'il soient convenablement qu'ils
informment le consommateur et notamment
il ne ficie pas des préférences
douanières qu' d'autres d'autres
produits et enfin la France a demandé
des sanctions sur les colons israéliens
violents enfin demander des sanctions
européennes madame la députée
tiet je crois qu'on peut dire que le
soutien à l'Ukraine est la priorité de
tous les membres de l'Union
européenne horis peut-être la Hongrie
qui effectivement s'est abstenue en
matière d'élargissement et la République
slovaque que nous n'avons pas beaucoup
entendu mais je suis sûre que vous serez
d'accord avec moi que la concomitance de
leurs orientations politiques et
peut-être pour certains leurs
accointances avec le régime russe ne
sont pas totalement étrangers à ces
positions mais sinon la priorité pour
tous et cela se reflète dans les
discussions sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel et le soutien à l'Ukraine
dans
la durée ensuite vous m'avez interrogé
sur l'aide financière nous sommes le
deuxè contributeur au budget de la
facilité européenne de paix qui permet
de fournir les armements à Kief nous
avons contribué à hauteur de 1,2
milliards d'euros ce qui représente à
peu près 18 % du budget total de 18 de 6
pardon,5 milliards d'euros et sur les
30000 sldat Ukrainiens qui sont formés
par la Mission militaire de l'Union
européenne la France en a formé 5000 et
puis je crois qu'il faut se souvenir que
la France a été le moteur dans la
création des instruments européens qui
permettront de renforcer nos industries
de défense et donc de pouvoir aider les
Ukrainiens sur sur la durée nous sommes
le moteur en matière de demande de
préférence européennees comme vous le
savez et nous mettons beaucoup l'accent
sur l'interopérabilité parce que
effectivement le sujet que vous avez
mentionné mérite des
progrès
madame la députée Gérard donc sur les
aides militaires et financières je crois
que j'ai répondu en partie je pense que
ce qu'il est important de dire c'est que
nous répondons en tant que de besoin à
la fois en terme de volume de qualité de
spécificité aux demandes ukrainiennes et
c'est vraiment des discussions qui vont
être au cœur de la stratégie de défense
que la Commission va présenter
mi-février 2024
entre l'Ukraine ce qui peut se passer
ailleurs dans le monde des l'évolution
peut-être sur le continent américain je
crois que l'ensemble des États-membres a
conscience qu'il nous faut vraiment
changer de vitesse et monter en
puissance en matière de de défense
monsieur le Président
chassigne les conditions sur pour ouvrir
le processus
d'adhésion de de négociation pardon à
l'adhésion qu'on que nous avons demandé
collectivement à l'Ukraine et à la
Moldavie porte sur l'état de droit et ça
c'est une première étape et comme vous
le savez
il y a l'état de droit la protection des
minorités en particulier hongroise sur
lesquel l'Ukraine a vraiment beaucoup
bougé en accord d'ailleurs avec ces
minorités et et ça c'est une première
étape puisque les deux étapes
importantes qui vont suivre seront la
définition du cadre de négociation
d'adhésion qui aura lieu plus tard
peut-être au courant prer semestre 24 et
ensuite la Conférence
intergouvernementale pour entériner et
lancer officiellement ce qui va se
passer les questions par parfaitement
légitime que vous avez sur la politique
agricole les politiques économiques
sanitaires social elles seront discutées
au moment de la formation du cadre donc
pas encore là vraiment l'accent était
sur l'état de droit et puis euh comme on
on se l' dit ici ça va prendre du temps
c'est une transformation profonde de la
société et de l'État ukrainien et même
si l'Ukraine va très rapidement comme la
Moldavie après l'adhésion il il y a
encore des périodes de transition je
veux vous rappeler par exemple que pour
l'Espagne il y avait une période de
transition de 10 ans sur les produits
agricoles après l'adhésion de l'Espagne
à l'Union européenne
ensuite pour votre question sur Israël
la France a toujours dit qu'Israël avait
le droit de se défendre dans le respect
du droit international et humanitaire et
comme je le disais tout à l'heure à la
députée au bonau quand il y a par
exemple des
actions lande de Colon nous les
condamnons et
pareil ailleurs et notamment l'accent
humanitaire sur Gaza je crois et la
volonté de coordination aussi des pays
de l'Union européenne a été largement
impulsée par la France et pour le coup
je crois que nous n'avons pas dévié sur
ces
sujets sur la solution à deux états et
la reconnaissance de l'État
palestinien je crois que nous sommes
tous d'accord que la solution à deux
états vivant côte à côté en FA et est
forcément la seule viable et c'est ce
que nous avons dit depuis longtemps et
et avec force je crois et il faut
évidemment que nous amenions Israël à
comprendre qu'un État palestinien va
être un facteur de sécurité pour eux et
je crois que c'est ce que la ministre
Colona disait dans une interview à la
tribune le 22 octobre donc la
reconnaissance la question d'
reconnaissance de l'État palestinien
elle doit être posée et bien sûr nous
veillerons et avec nos partenaires à ce
qu'elle le soit au moment qui sera le
plus utile à la relance d'un processus
de paix je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre il me reste trois questions
pour le moment en commençant par Nicole
lepet pour le groupe Renaissance et pour
2 minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre la semaine dernière
le Conseil européen a décidé d'engager
des négociations d'adhésion avec donc
l'Ukraine et la Moldavie la Georgie donc
obtient quant à elle le statut de
candidat c'est une des décisions
historiques pour l'Europe et ces trois
pays et nous pouvons que nous en
féliciter cependant la procédure
d'intégration suscite vous le savez
l'inquiétude de certains secteurs
notamment celui de l'agriculture les
perspectives d'une forme de doping
social qui laisse entrevoir l'entrée de
l'Ukraine dans l'Union européenne
inquiète une partie des agriculteurs
européens alors les agriculteurs
français et polonais notamment pourut
nous citer queeux surveillent de très
près la situation d'autant plus qu'il y
a déjà un contentieux entre Varsovie et
Kiev concernant les céréales
ukrainiennes aussi madame la ministre
comment pourrions-nous rassurer nos
producteurs pour que l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine considérée comme le grenier à
blé de l'Europe ne déstabilise pas le
modèle économique de notre agriculture
européenne et j'ai bien entendu la
nécessaire période de transition je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Grégoire de fournass pour le groupe
rassemblement national pour 2 minutes ça
marche merci monsieur le Président dans
la continuité de la question qui vient
de vous être posé madame la ministre je
voudrais vous interroger sur donc le
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
avec l'Ukraine un pays qui pèse
l'équivalent du quart de l'agriculture
européenne avec un modèle d'agriculture
radicalement différente différent de
l'agriculture française un chiffre
madame la ministre la plus grande
exploitation ukrainienne fait 700000
hectares ce qui évidemment n'a rien à
voir avec l'agriculture française si
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine entraîn
entraînerait mécaniquement une baisse de
20 % des subventions de la PAC pour les
agriculteurs à budget constant elle
deviendrait surtout un concurrent
impitoyable pour l'agriculture française
votre collègue ministre de l'Agriculture
a tenté plusieurs fois nous rassurer en
nous garantissant une harmonisation des
normes ukrainiennes avec les normes
européennes mais madame la ministre
permettez-moi de vous rappeler qu'il n'y
a toujours pas dans au sein du du marché
commun au sein de l'Union européenne une
harmonisation des normes
environnementales et sociales puisque
l'Union européenne est le premier
concurrent de l'agriculture française
aujourd'hui et c'est d'ailleurs rappelé
dans un rapport qui sortira demain de
notre collègue Dominique potier euh nous
sommes évidemment solidaire de l'Ukraine
mais votre responsabilité madame la
ministre c'est de protéger les intérêts
de la France quelle garantie euh allez
vous apporter au aux agriculteurs je
suis pas dans la même question que
Madame madame le P il ne s'agit pas de
rassurer les agriculteurs mais de mais
plutôt d'apporter des garanties
sérieuses que vous vous ne permettrez
pas que le le géant ukrainien soit un
concurrent impitoyable encore une fois
pour les agriculteurs
français merci beaucoup la parole est à
Jean-Pierre pont pour le groupe
renaissance pour 2 minutes merci
monsieur le Président merci Madame le
Ministre de votre présence permettez-moi
de de revenir sur la vie politique
que nous avons pris il y a 15 jours ici
comme vous le savez suite au passage de
la tempête siant a des épisodes
plusvieux intens et continue la région
des Haut- de-fance et tout
particulièrement le pas dequ a subit des
inondations exceptionnelles plusieurs
centaines de communes sont sous les eaux
ont compte 200000 habitations commerces
bâtiments et entreprises sinistrées et
plus de 200 établissements scolaires
contraint la fermeture des milliers
d'hectares de cultur perdu des milliers
de personnes déplacées bref une immense
catastrophe qui n'en est pas à son terme
puisque la descru est extrêmement lente
avec des terres gorgé d'eau qui
n'absorbbe plus dans ma circonscription
du boulognais le tiers des communes a
été submergé par la rivière liane
l'ensemble des dégâts va probablement
dépasser le milliard la région des
haut--fance a décidé de prendre en
charge les franchises prévues par les
contrats des sinistrés et le
gouvernement de classer les événements
en catastrophe naturell et en calamnité
agricole tout cela malheureusement ne
peut suffire à reconstruire en zone
inondées routes pont éces bâtiments
industriels dig et systèmes de pompage
madame la ministre comment pouvons-nous
mobiliser collectivement pour activer
les mécanismes de solidarité européenne
pour venir en aide au territoires
sinistrés et plus particulièrement pour
répondre d'urgence à ma demande déjà
formulée en faveur des sinistriés des
Haut- de France sur le long terme nous
avons que les crises climatiques que ce
soit les inondations les sécheresses ou
les incendies vont se multiplier c'est
pourquoi nous avons adopté il y a 2
semaines en commission un avis politique
sur la réponse européenne aux crises
climatiques je souhaite remercier
vivement le président Anglade ainsi que
tous mes collègues députés qui se sont
associés à cette démarche j'en appelle
dans ma communication politique à une
réflexion de fond sur la réponse
européenne aux crises climatiques
comment selon vous la politique
européenne d'adaptation au changement
climatique peut-elle prendre en compte
la prévention des effets des
catastrophes climatiques et comment
notamment soutenir nos agriculteurs je
vous remercie merci beaucoup et enfin la
parole est à char St pour le groupe
Renaissance et pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre alors moi j'ai deux
sujets que je voulais évoquer avec vous
le premier c'est plus des remerciements
vous vous souvenez peut-être que lors de
votre première audition de vot devant
notre commission à l'été 2022 je vous
avez interrogé sur le sujet osmose et
donc le sujet j'avais demandé que
qu'allait faire le gouvernement français
sur ce sujet vous m'aviez dit que le
gouvernement allait tout faire pour que
le dossier osmose aboutisse et donc
c'est bien le cas puisqu'il y a quelques
jours la première ministre avec la
présidente du Parlement européen ont ont
inauguré ce qui s'appelle désormais le
bâtiment Simone veille à côté du du
bâtiment actuel du Parlement européen à
Strasbourg et donc c'est un moment
important dans la place du Parlement
européen à Strasbourg et qui renforce
très concrètement le siège
strasbourgeois et c'est c'est le fruit
d'un travail de de l'État français au
cours des des derniers mois et puis plus
largement d'un d'un soutien qui n'a
jamais souffert d'ambiguïé du président
de la République depuis 2017 vis-à-vis
Strasbourg donc je voulais vraiment au
nom des Alsaciens vous remercier le
deuxème sujet l'Ukraine c'est un dossier
fondamental pour l'Europe c'est l'avenir
la sécurité du continent qui est en jeu
le respect du droit international et la
stabilité aussi de nos démocraties il
faut toujours le rappeler l'Ukraine a
besoin de notre soutien soutien
financier militaire pour se défendre
vous l'avez rappelé aussi besoin de
notre soutien politique et c'est le sens
de la décision historique du Conseil
européen d'avoir ouvert les négociations
d'adhésion avec Kief nous le savons ce
processus qui s'ouvre sera long sera
difficile sera exigeant les partenaires
Ukrainiens sont au courant nous l'avons
mesuré avec le président Pierre-Henri
Dumont et Frédéric petit lorsque nous
étions à Kief au mois dernier nous
savons que notamment dans la lutte
contre la corruption et l'agriculture
beaucoup d'efforts seront demandé au aux
Ukrainiens mais en tout cas c'est le
sens qui a été donné lors de cette
décision du Conseil européen et ma
question était de savoir comment est-ce
que concrètement se passera la
discussion des chapitres et selon quel
calendrier merci beaucoup merci à tous
pour vos questions madame le ministre
vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
peut-être je vais faire une réponse
collective sur l'Ukraine si ça convient
à tout le monde d'accord la première
chose que je voudrais dire c'est que
nous voulons que l'Ukraine la Moldavie
les Balcans occidentaux la Géorgie
accroissent et améliore leurs standards
d'État de droit de lutte contre la
corruption de principes démocratiques
d'indépendance et pluralité de la
justice d'indépendance et impartialité
des médias pardon oui des médias au
niveau des standards européens nous ne
voulons pas que ces pays soient des
sources d'instabilité aux frontières de
l'Union européenne ou des interférences
et des ingérences russes puissent nous
déstabiliser comme c'est le cas par
exemple en Slovaquie mais pas qu'en
Slovaquie dans d'autres pays donc ils
vont être avec nous ou dérivver loin de
nous donc l'idée c'est de les ancrer
auprès de nous et de renforcer un
continent qui est déjà 440 millions de
personnes pour en faire un de 500
millions de personnes qui vivent dans la
démocratie État de droit comme et on ne
peut que leur souhaiter d'avoir des
commissions parlementaires aussi
plurielles respectueuses et qui savent
débattre dans la sérénité de sujets
importants bien
sûr voilà c'est c'est la le premier
point et c'est ça je crois la
géopolitique et la géostabilité dont
plusieurs d'entre vous que plusieurs
d'entre vous ont mentionné à ce stade
c'est vraiment l'État de droit qui va
permettre de déclencher le calendrier
suivant qui va être caractérisé par deux
étapes majeures sur laquelle je rappelle
que tous les pays ont un droit de vetto
à ce stade et à chaque étape et qui est
là pour la première définir le cadre de
négociation et bien et ensuite de le
lancer le processus avec une conférence
intergouvernementale le cadre de
négociation va nous permettre de
préciser quelles sont les demandes en
matière d'adoption des acquis dans tous
les domaines de la politique économique
y compris la politique bien évidemment
agricole mais pas que l'objectif étant
aussi que nous ayons une convergence en
matière économique et sociale et que les
salaires augmentent progressivement pour
rejoindre ceux de l'Union européenne de
façon à ce que nous ayons en bon
français un level playing field et donc
c'est comme cela qu'on arrivera pardon à
des des conditions de travail des
conditions de salaire qui soient à peu
près équivalentes dans tout t les pays
pour avoir une concurrence qui n'est pas
déloyale
sur sur la PAC et la politique de
cohésion il est évident que nous allons
devoir changer des choses et ce serait
absolument pas juste de ne pas dire ça
et c'est bien pour ça que la France a
insisté tout le temps pour qu'il y ait
une réforme de l'Union européenne
elle-même en même temps qu'on demandait
aux candidats de se réformer et ce que
nous voulons faire c'est c'est que ces
politiques puissent continuer de jouer
un rôle important et notamment dans les
anciens États-membres et surtout ceux
qui sont contributeurs comme les nôtres
et
évidemment dans ce cadre le gouvernement
va défendre les intérêts des
agriculteurs lorsque les négociations
avec les pays candidats se tiendront et
évidemment nous redemanderons les
périodes de transition en tant que de
besoin pour qu'on nit pas que nos
agriculteurs ne soient pas affectés nous
l'avons fait pour l'agriculture nous
l'avons fait pour les pêcheurs euh nous
le faisons pour les producteurs de vin
et nous continuerons de Cognac de de
tout ce que euh tous les beaux pays tous
les beaux produits que la France euh
produit et nous continuerons euh de le
faire et c'est dans le cadre de
négociation que nous pouvons inscrire ça
donc les garanties monsieur le député
sttien tool que vous demandez elles
seront inscrite bien évidemment à ce euh
moment-là euh je vais en profiter et j'
j'espère que vous m'en voudrez pas
monsieur ponce pour remercier Charles
pour ses mots pour osmos c'est vrai que
ça a été une grande bataille qu'on a
absolument pas lâché et qu'on est je
crois très content aujourd'hui d'avoir
que la première ministre ait pu
inaugurer le bâtiment de Simon veille le
21 novembre dernier qui à la fois sécure
le siège du Parlement européen à
Strasbourg mais qui va aussi renforcer
les services qui qui sont à Strasbourg
et je crois que c'est important pour
l'emploi dans la
région et pour et pour renforcer en fait
la dynamique économique de Strasbourg et
ses environs et je vais finir par le
fond de solidarité de l'Union
européenne qui effectivement a été créé
en 2002 pour faire face aux innovations
aux inondations pardon qui avaient
touché l'Europe centrale la même année
qui a été aussi sollicité cet été quand
la Slovénie a connu des innovations
assez des je vais y arriver des
inondations assez assez dramatiques
Slovénie avec laquelle nous parlons
beaucoup pour effectivement préserver et
réfléchir à comment adapter le soutien
que l'Union européenne apporte dans
l'adaptation au changement climatique et
pas que dans la et pas que dans la PR
prévention et pas que dans l'atténuation
pardon voilà le mot que je cherchais
après
alors le fond il permet de couvrir une
partie des dépenses publiques qui sont
engagées comme la remise en fonction des
infrastructures les équipements dans le
domaine de l'eau des télécommunications
des transports la santé
l'enseignement que vous connaissez bien
nous avons averti la commission que nous
voulions avoir recours au
fsue et les services du gouvernement
sont en train de travailler au côté des
services déconcentrés pour réaliser le
dossier de demande d'utilisation du fsue
le plus rapidement possible puisque nous
avons un dilet de 10 semaines à partir
de la survenue du premier dommage causé
par la catastrophe nation naturelle
évidemment nous devons faire état de la
totalité des dégâts qui ont été composés
par les intempéries et dresser en fait
la demande de contribution
financière pour avoir une réponse de la
Commission européenne donc si vous m'y
autorisez je voudrais aussi en profiter
pour faire un petit appel à la
mobilisation des services déconcentrés
puisque ce sont les premiers de cordé
qui font remonter les dégâts constatés
sur le territoire il faut absolument
qu'il soit mobilisé pour nous aider à
débloquer l'enveloppe au titre du fsue
et je vous remercie
d' merci beaucoup merci pour ce ce
compte-rendu exhaustif et d'avoir
répondu avec précision aux questions qui
vous ont été posées s'il y a plus
d'autres demandes de de prise de parole
je vous propose qu'on lève notre réunion
de ce jour on vous remercions à nouveau
pour votre disponibilité et votre
présence aujourd'hui c'était important
c'est un conseil euh assez assez
singulier donc il y avait beaucoup de
beaucoup de questions je vous souhaite à
toutes et tous de de bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année un Joyeux Noël un bon repos et
je vous souhaite de vous retrouver en
forme à la rentrée merci beaucoup et à
bientôt